bientôt monde sait ce qu est aujourd'hui
on se retrouve un peu tardivement il est
vrai sur daylight les sorties ya un mois
et j'ai pas fait de doute eu alors que
c'est l'un des jets d'eau voire
incontournable cette année ok d'accord
l'année qui me voler mon téléphone va
bien à bientôt voilà concentre toi ça
car ne m'ont pas beaucoup de torts
utilise cette machine dans ta main pour
trouver son chemin
il ya beaucoup à voir et beaucoup à
apprendre oui d'accord tétouan le guide
j'ai jamais de demander de guide ou
suis-je plus tard il est carrément
bottes je sais quoi ça très bien la pub
pour vache qui rit datant de 1722 j'ai
ramassé une note qui dit fuyez poids bon
allez à bientôt
ouais le chemin utilise la lumière pour
trouver les réponses d'accord non
connaisseurs de bâton de berger un peu
périmées
ok c'est bon j'ai le bâton j'ai le bâton
lumineux un nombre d'incidents étranges
effrayant survie du peuple sorti
l'hôpital au podium non un plan se
dessine sur mon bras mais n'y a eu aucun
rejet des voix ça y est on me parle je
perds je pensais que je pouvais utiliser
ya déjà des bruits méga de l'eau de
partout [ __ ] arrêté un moment aussi où
on au quai des arts c'est juste la fumée
en ouvrant la porte d'accord donc déjà
la femme de ménage est aussi loin de cet
endroit il ya combien double porte je
sais que vous êtes là acquis par intel
ouais c'était qui c'étaient les meufs
qui a créé la pub vache qui rit 2722 là
c'est ça non mais a été très bien ta pub
le bas tombe berger ouais et aux eaux
aux mondieux pitié mais c'est bon c'est
juste un dessin tu as pu pardonner ça
quand même qu'est ce qui se passe là qui
a collé ses housses de couette au
plafond l'aca pas du tout krainer flamme
ça certains avantages ne pourront pas
couché ouais y'a des fois c'est les
placards a été de me parler latin au
temps des choses bouger pendant que je
nettoie et je te jure que c'est pas des
rats c'est beaucoup plus gros jeu c'est
beaucoup bah oui c'est sanglier aux
ailes ça continue je vais des flammes
attention la flamme des taux qu dans le
culte du tas du coup j'ai gâché un bâton
web d'un phoque
quel est ce délire ok t'as du coup je
suis très tortueux quoi
si je mets comme ça normalement je suis
un caméléon étant donné que moi aussi
j'ai des tatouages comme ça par ce corps
à moins que c'est une vision
qu'est ce que c'est possible ce sujet
j'ai une vision bon ouais ok ça marche
j'ai pas trop compris mais tu vas
arrêter d'aller dans le passé maintenant
tu vas rester ici s'il te plaît tu seras
peut-être est mignonne c'était là ça
avant je sais pas peut-être yes ok mon
ours en peluche
ces beautés dit [ __ ] sauvegarde en
cours
vous savez ce que j'en pense vous savez
sur un prime après voilà alors qu'est ce
qu'on va en débattons de berger superbe
qui y jouent la guitare ah non acquis et
ses inventions du jeu ça marche l'homme
pas trop paniquer il y avait quoi de
l'autre côté une porte aussi d'accord
donc c'est ici ou ici bas écouter on va
passer par d'accord donc c'est d'accord
donc déjà ok un gros amas de gaza ici
aussi c'est quoi ça vous gardez vos
fringues hk je ne joue pas à cache cache
un mois je vous cache à peine daniel été
retrouvé mort dans ces quartiers ce
matin d'accord donc c'est madame
danielle qui veut jouer à chat je
suppose
ah ah ah ah mais oui madame danielle si
vous chercher le bâton de berger c'est
moi qui laissait planer madame danièle
herry dao madame danielle stop stop stop
elle en fait madame danielle je sais ça
tellement de peine et de souffrance et
venant de ceux qui ne cherchent que le
répit d'accord qu'est ce qui te presse
sarah bas peut-être toi gros conac à la
pomme n'a pas l'air je suis dans
l'endroit de pouliot exoplanètes faut
que le pouce comme ça que je fasse un
petit un petit peu de breakdance avec
ok une fois qu'on a fini on relâche on
re saute dessus sur celle ci oui
qu'est-ce donc appuyé au ca marche aux
essais le numéro de patricia découvre
elle a marché sur un bout de bois de 30
cm de large et un peu glissé la bière
fort allait du coup je faut que j'en
passe par là que j'allais à droite cette
fois j'espère qu'il y aura personne
dorme et personnes oui mais bon pas ce
poids non plus quoi je les appelle de
flash on sait jamais donc c'est bienvenu
là attendez attendez je ne pars pas sans
mes bâtons berger s'il vous plaît au
maine pourquoi c'est bon j'ai une
multiprise je te brancher mon portable
ma ds mon truc danse ou alors partir à
l'aventuré aussi oui mais bon d'accord
la photo un peu glauque j'ai bien
famille transcende le temps et la
matière bordel il fait tellement noir
[ __ ] mais j'approuve tellement ce que
tu vas me dire ah ah
on monte on descend il va falloir
descendre bien sûr la hauteur c'est pas
bon direct vallée des saints on est
content monsieur une sorte de shrek
il fallait descendre mais n'y avait pas
de chat qui est pas de shrek un feu de
bengale allumé peut se servir vous
protéger je veux pas le mec est allé
sans ça je vais direct tout ce qui se
passe je suis protégé situé à faire mon
gars je suis chômeur bora je sais que
vous êtes là dans la personne ici un
ferme ta bouche non qu'est-ce qui se
passe quelqu'un est là bien sûr il ya
quelqu'un tombait la somme il brouille à
la seconde bordel de merde
bon sang on n'y voit rien ah merci
captain obvious bravo ok la porte du
paradis au plus jamais ça madame
danielle je sais que c'est vous j'en
sais rien mais on va dire que c'est vous
oh la piche vous entendez ces bruits
[ __ ] militants devront tu ne nous
croit je sais qu'il ya quelqu'un non il
n'y a personne heures tu arrêtes de dire
ça pour me faire peur voir dave stresse
pas t'inquiète pas tout va bien aller ok
en fait tu ne manques et là tu peut se
passer
ne viens pas me voir j'ai un bâton je
suis très dangereux il est pas foutu de
retirer cette barre pour que je puisse
passer
[ __ ] et pendant que j'y sois mon truc
qui se consume bêtement la faille à la
fab karoshi lula qui voit dans les
flaques d'eau qui veut poursuivre à
moins de jeux ouvertes et alors ça plus
jamais mais merci en tout cas assez
gentil je m'assois chez un petit post
qu'est ce qui se passe au froid tout ça
ok on a une vision ô mon dieu m'a coupé
les cheveux aux pizzas fait du sens et
plus aucune bouteille
ok c'est pour ses partis alliés des fois
j'ai des voix non je vous ignorent non
là j'entends pas j'entends pas à la
blague de l'omc ashton et demi et
quelqu'un au-dessus [ __ ] mais il ya
une sorte d'ogre au-dessus espen black
bordel comme suis heureux on n'y est pas
qu ils pas qu'ils passaient bon on y est
on y est on y est yes 2006 aux halles et
2006 aux jeux sauvegardés en cours les
ports des jeux peu de surprises sarah
passage secret oh oui yes j'ai toujours
été sur cela ce ponton bon si tu
continues j'active un brouillard et je
recevrai plus des messages d'accord
d'accord donc à une sorte de bruit de
moto un [ __ ] on va y avoir un gros mot
oh oh attention à toi jeune monstre va
encore falloir trouver si vestiges là et
avant de décéder cayla cayla qui est là
au [ __ ] voit la légion feux de bengale
contre un fauteuil roulant et merde
alain detournay je trouvais aucun
vestige pour le moment et je l'indiqué
mon seul feux de bengale on peut parler
de mon espérance de vie si vous voulez a
pas de problème
l'état mais c'est parce que j'ai trouvé
feux de bengale via la créature obscures
a tamponné voilà maintenant tu peux bien
là haut il n'y a rien oh oh non pas et
wet wet pas les toilettes mais où cette
porte là au lieu du nom mais ouvre et
ensuite parce voilà comment passer une
porte en deux secondes tutorial exclusif
c'est ce qui m'arrive je sais pas mais
non mais les portes et on a dit qu'on
s'en foutent et aux daft punk et celle
qui brûle brûle en de rage à l'image de
ton dédain comment ça se passe qui veut
faire une partie de dominos toi
peut-être d'accord c'était que sa
créature de l'ombre foulée pajot de
musées avec toi [ __ ] oui ouvre toi
oh non je refais la gagner juste à
gauche je perds à garder le jeu super
gars des baptêmes daniel tu continues
c'est le cas des correspondances à
madame danielle
non la tequila veille sont fatales
marche pour la première fois dans
l'histoire d'un jeu d'horreur mais bien
là dans une allée population au delà des
styles
[ __ ] faut pourtant en arrivera si on a
eu tous les tous les vestiges mais non
mais ça paye tout faire je peux tout
d'accord avec cette idée que j'ai
moi-même proposait donc je vais peut
être pas d'accord avec une idée assez
moyens proposés mais bon sang baisse
j'ose plus marcher quoi mais il faut en
fait de bain de bain de benjamin un feu
de bain de bungalows où un feu de bain
alors au va chier vachier au [ __ ]
et c'est ça que vous et wat
t'as faim tu avais c'est très bien de se
repérer en marchant à reculons pour pas
mourir à cause d'une beach c'est l'amour
entre nous yes yes yes
[ __ ] [ __ ] faut courage mon gars
poker ou comment sommes-nous wolf au
[ __ ] m et mes fesses sales arrête net
quoi corps comme si sa vie en dépendait
puisque à leurs dépens qu'est ce que
c'est que ça me sert troisième fois que
tu fais ça [ __ ] hockey une femme vers
des barreaux une vision à 22 heures une
explosion de zone de l'explosion
tellement de brutalité de corruption et
le chaos je suis bien d'accord ont
couvert la liberté la liberté la liberté
à lille en bateau
hop on me vole ma bible mais au moins ça
ouvre la porte
c'est sauvegarder j'ouvre cette porte je
regarde ici je fais des appels de flash
au mur qui me répond par un petit rien
du tout vous dire que ça ne fonctionne
pas pour l'instant ça marche à que la
lumière soit et la lumière fut
et voilà les gens c'est déjà fin de
cette première vidéo sur des blogs
j'espère qu'il vous aura plu si c'est le
cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo ça fera
vraiment plaisir
je ne sais pas si j'en ferai d'autres
pour cause d'un caleçon plutôt
mécontents qui manifestent actuellement
dans mon salon si vous voulez construire
leur expulsion ensemble n'hésitez pas à
dire dans les commentaires et si vous
voulez pas n'hésitez pas à dire aussi
que je sache
en tout cas je comprends pourquoi on va
autant parler de ce jeu il est vraiment
extrêmement effrayant je vous dis à
bientôt une nouvelle vidéo chat ou le
monde
pis
c'est